uh I don't know if you guys have heard  have you heard any have we talked about  this at all something about Powerball  yeah somebody could become a maybe a  double billionaire later tonight this is  a live look down at Prim with a lot of  hopefuls lining up hoping to get that  nearly two billion dollar jackpot after  nowhere on Saturday night  that is crazy if somebody wins it will  set a new record for the largest Lottery  prize ever either nearly two billion  dollars over 29 years or one lump sum of  929 million all at once drawing happens  tonight at eight o'clock the odds of  winning it all well there's still one in  292  million wow 0.2 million people  chances yeah chances for people to win